parasail macroeconomics seems to be a
common term here that what is the main
question of macroeconomics textbook in
basic economics it usually talks about
business cycles about short-run
fluctuations in economic activity like
unemployment is up or inflation is up or
down
this type of macroeconomics is a little
different you find it in textbooks but
it's very different because it's about a
longer run where economic growth comes
from so so actually the textbooks have
been changed quite a lot since Romer did
his work and so that yes actually the
the part of the book that is about the
long-run issues has become longer and
many textbooks start with that now where
when they used to start with business
cycles well what was Paul Romer say
about that
oh he asks where it comes from I mean he
wanted to understand why some countries
grow and other countries don't grow and
also why though why the world grows at
the rate it does and what explains
technological progress and I think it
was by asking the question that he came
up with ways of thinking about it that
influenced a lot of other researchers
and it led to both empirical work and
theoretical work and actually an
explosion in research so what is the
main motor of economic growth it I think
almost all economists would say its
technological change but the question is
where does that come from like what why
does it happen and when does it happen
you know nothing happened during the
many hundred years before the Industrial
Revolution in terms of technological
change and then it all exploded but it
hasn't been totally even and but it's
been ongoing since the Industrial
Revolution and and a 2 percent per year
the the leading countries are just kind
of growing and growing and it's because
of technological change and in what way
did Paul Romer explain think about why
it occurs and what are the good
preconditions for healthy growth and he
thought about things like how societies
organized in terms of patent systems in
terms of subsidies to oranjee so it's
not enough to have universities because
universities are crucial and there there
are people there at universities like
Romer himself they are rewarded by this
wonderful prizes but you also need
research in the market and that's what
he focused on so what makes it happen in
the market what what are the
circumstances you know judicial system
all kinds of things that create the
conditions for technological growth
that's what he was interested in then
you have to realize that once you come
up with great ideas it's important that
they spread that they spread to other
countries so so many countries I think
or or not original innovators but they
adopt technical ideas different kind of
products and ideas are different yes
exactly and by thinking deeply about why
ideas are so different than regular
shoo-shoo type products its then you get
some other clue to how to think about it
and it was led to think about many ideas
are super cheap to replicate once you
get them but it's it's all about getting
the ideas and then that's when all these
institutional preconditions come in that
allow some profits but not too much
profits because you don't want to
restrict it too much and how to manage
that is a central problem and I think
all the people who are at governments
around the world these days they think
about it the way he thinks about it we
save read the textbooks now and they
they understood that ideas are different
and and and that's just a framework for
thinking so somehow you have to give
birth to ideas but who has the
responsibility for that
well they if you live in market
economies it's not that this anybody
responsible you need to happen by itself
and that's what the market does these
things and it does it usually fairly
well but he also pointed to how it
doesn't do it enough maybe I'm in a case
of ideas so if he emphasizes that you
need to give people patents that last
for a while to give them proper
incentives to do things to to innovate
and and and you may also need to
subsidize research and development ideas
and so I think governments are to some
extent responsible but a lot of it
happens by just market activity so it's
both and the other part of the price has
to do with climate change and this is
really a very hard problem that involves
so many different parts of society
everything so how can one model with
well I think what what what Nordhaus did
was that he became very interested in
other sciences after his PhD degree
maybe even before I don't know but he
did this interdisciplinary thing which
is very fashionable today but I think in
the 1970s it was a very common that an
economist would dig deep into Natural
Sciences and also discover climate
change as a potentially big problem I
mean most people for sure most
economists didn't think about it and
many others didn't either so so I guess
you had the early realization that you
needed to connect all these things and
build a framework for thinking about
them together so I think a lot of what
he did was to simplify the natural
science bits to the point where he could
think about them jointly with economics
so there is sort of you need to take
existing knowledge
make it digestible digestible for for
people like himself and for other
economists and ultimately for
policymakers so that that was a quite an
effort and in the in the early days he
he he asked limited questions but still
super interesting questions like what's
the best way of not exceeding two
degrees of warming a question that most
people are super interested in today he
asked like 40 years ago but then he
asked more ambitious questions which is
okay but what is the best thing to do
overall let's not restrict attention
just to a particular temperature goal
how should we think about maybe what's
the right temperature golden and so on
so he he needed to invest for decades
before he was ready to adjust these more
difficult questions and as I said in my
presentation today in the press
conference it's we don't have final
answers but now can if we can just
follow in his footsteps and if you don't
like exactly what it did on this we
change it and and that's what
everybody's doing now around the world
and the most last report from this night
is the IPCC says that we have to stop
the growth of temperature to at 1.5 yeah
I haven't I haven't had time to read it
because it just it came out at midnight
so not too many hours ago so I have to
look carefully and see what it says 1.5
degrees is it okay idea there was to say
what would it take to get us to not
exceed one and a half so it's I don't
think that the point was we mustn't
exceed one and a half it was more what
would it take is it even possible and I
think they that's my reading without
having studied it carefully and the
question is they say it's possible it's
very very hard and it takes things like
special efforts to remove carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere relying on future
technology to to do the job and
but that's the kind of thing that Romer
was interested in so the two areas are
connected that way
well what would be the volume not that I
was answer to this ambition to limit the
growth of temple I am Not sure because I
just know that he has said that without
advance new type of geoengineering or
advanced types of removing carbon
dioxide he I don't think he thinks it's
possible but that doesn't mean that he
thinks we shouldn't try it I think he
says it's extremely difficult and you
have to rely on future technologies for
doing these things to work out don't
succeed I think what he would say if I
may guess is that you should also figure
out how much it costs to do that it's
not just a matter of doing it at any
cost
so there is still a cost benefit
calculation there I think it would
answer but you would have to ask him for
the details but what are the policy
recommendations to somehow curve them
for a long time been pushing the idea of
just using global carbon tax I mean try
to agree that all countries or large
regions of countries should tax carbon
and as an economist this is can obvious
solution I think it's gaining momentum
the notion of using carbon taxes I think
the ideas a little bit that if you have
a sizeable carbon tax it will do several
things but one of them is to eliminate a
lot of fossil fuel that's not really so
productive anyway where it's it's
marginally profitable and then it will
not be used if it there's a tax on top
of that and that that's a good thing but
it might also induce more new
technologies that can replace fossil
fuel that will be out competed so I'm
guessing that this is what he would say
but I want to emphasize that the prize
is not given for
any particular policy conclusions this
boy it's more methodological price so
it's really kind of the tools we need to
answer the kind of questions you were
asking me now no not to kind of say what
to do and that's it
so in part I'm just speculating and
we'll see what he has to say when it
comes to Stockholm thank you very much
back yourself